the Russian government's lies have been
exposed by one of President Putin's own
henchmen now the full story of this
weekend's weekend's events and the
long-term effects will take some time to
become clear and it is not helpful to
speculate propagation's Rebellion is an
unprecedented challenge to President
Putin's Authority and it is clear that
cracks are emerging in the Russian
support for the War I of course hold no
candle for propagation or his forces
they have committed atrocities in
Ukraine and elsewhere but here said out
loud what we have believed since the
start of Russia's full-scale Invasion
that this invasion was both unjustified
and unprovoked the events of this
weekend are unprecedented challenge to
Putin's Authority with an armored column
approaching his own capital city